um in much the same way that oh it's all
over there in much the same way that
when we're finding points right we just
had to kind of put some values in see
what happened okay I kind of have to do
the same thing for this graph for
certain points okay but thankfully it's
not it's not impossible right for
instance we know that the square root of
zero is zero so anywhere where my
original graph
has a y value of zero I will still be
zero and there's exactly one spot where
is that
on the x-axis and specifically at x
equals one that's what we found out
right okay so what I'm going to do is on
my graph I'm going to put like a big fat
and if you've got other colors here it
does help because you can see how much
stuff goes on here right okay I've got
that bit there was another spot that I
knew that the square root of that number
gives me back that number itself
one one very good that's here
I'm destroying my marker that's fine
that's okay all right so I know I go
through those two points and then I just
have to think about this logic in here
right so I know that
um when I've got values greater than one
that was like four and nine and sixteen
when you take a square root you end up
smaller okay so let's have a look where
do you see those
um see all of these values here they're
greater than one they're between one and
two right so therefore as you take the
square root you'll be just below this
section of the graph now see how this is
asymptotic behavior it's going towards
two
now what we're saying is you're going to
approach like this is y equals the
square root of f of x right so over here
you're getting values closer and closer
to two underneath that square root
so instead of approaching 2 you're going
to approach what
way away from what um what value what
value have a think
this is two and I'm just taking the
square root right yeah so if for example
you actually um get your calculator
there somewhere that's why that's okay
if you put some values in like x equals
negative 10 negative 100 negative a
thousand you're going to get this whole
thing
be closer to because this thing takes
over then to the whole thing you apply a
square root over the whole thing right
so you're going to get very close to the
square root
of two do you agree with that like if f
of x in fact why don't we write some
notation under this because it'll help
right I'm going to borrow some um uh
notation from like last year okay so if
I said
the limit
of f of x
as X goes
further and further towards negative
Infinity okay I already know what that's
equal to it's two because that's what
that asymptote tells me okay so now if I
say the limit
or as X approaches that same it's going
to the left okay
now I'm not going to look at the
function I'm going to look at the square
root of the function
well if you took the square root of this
side you just take the square root of
the other side does that make sense
because you're actually just going to
put in numbers that a question requested
a 2 and you'll take the square root of
those numbers so um square root of two
you know what that's equal to
it's closer 1.4 you're thinking it's
square root of three which is also also
comes up a lot because of trig like
Roots round two all that anyway square
root of two it's about 1.4 so let's go
ahead you can see why it's so important
to have like a good graph if that's one
and that's two 1.4 is going to be like
their ish right
like so okay so it's a bit lower and
because horizontal asymptotes tend to do
this thing on both sides I'm actually
going to extend it over there and we'll
see why in a minute
so what I've got is I am going to
approach this asymptote from underneath
just like I had before okay
this part here is weird we were talking
about this before
when you've got y values or f of x
values that are little when you take the
square root they get higher
so you see how this little section in
here is below this section here is going
to be
above
which is weird but I'm going to start
here I've got to be above in this
section but then I've got to come back
down to you told me the square root of
this value intersects with itself right
what kind of shape would that look like
yeah yeah it's round right it starts
here ends here but I've got to be above
that's really badly done there's hand
drawn so I think like you've got the
rough idea here can you see it's kind of
like a steeper version here and then a
shallower version here in fact if I did
this again I would rub this out and I
would do one clean line that just goes
through okay
all right now what happens past here
what does what happens when I take the
square root of this
existing at least it does in the real
numbers right
um if we were talking about complex
numbers which we're not
um those answers do exist but this is a
real app number and this is a real
number so we just say that the square
root of that function just stops right
there no problem okay all right now
lastly what happens over here okay now
what you want to do here is you actually
want to get a decent sense of what's
going on so remember I said like you're
gonna need some values right
often when you get given a question like
this and say the HSC they'll even
provide you a grid so you can do this
with some
scale and accuracy but say for example
if I put in a value like I'm thinking of
one that would work
um
if I put in a value like
four I'm choosing four I'm going to rub
off this because I don't need it if I
chose a value like four I'm choosing it
because it gives me really easy numbers
so I go f of four what's that equal to
can you help me out yeah because you go
to over this this is just going to be 2
divided by two which is one and then you
added that two so that's why it gives
you three okay so I know the reason why
I've picked this is because I can say
all right there's two here's I've got x
equals four so it's going to be there
right so this value up here actually
should be lower down my graphs are not
that accurate so in fact let's just
redraw it there's no reason why not okay
so let's just make that a little more
accurate like
there that looks like about three to me
you okay with that okay so now this is a
bit more accurate of a shape like so
this is the original function but now
I'm going to take the square root
it's not going to be three it's going to
be the square root of three that's the
1.7 you were telling me about before
right so therefore where's 1.7 it's
going to be somewhere around here right
and then just like this approaches root
2 I didn't label that much a bit cheeky
just as this approaches root 2 from the
bottom this side is going to approach
root 2. from the top is that okay so if
I place that 1.7 around there or so so
I'm going to get a very similar shape
on this side but it'll always be can you
see it's always beneath why is it all
why is it always beneath
it's very good values above one when you
take that square root they always get
smaller always smaller every square root
value that you test out if you test it
out a bunch you wouldn't just get three
and root three you get like four root 4
and then five and root 5 always
underneath okay
that's pretty much it
now
how do you feel about that process were
there any bits of it that were unclear
to you or didn't make sense
no that was I get that and I'm pretty
sure that the second part says wise word
yes fantastic
oh that's a great question so oopsie
Daisy um we've just done the hard part
this next part is actually the easy bit
so y squared equals f of x right if you
had if I had gave to you uh let's just
forget about this for a minute let's
just if I gave you numbers right if I
said I had some number a and when you
scratch you get 16 what can you tell me
about a
because there's two values that satisfy
it right so what this is telling us is
the same deal there's two values that
satisfy this right they're both going to
be this same magnitude but you get the
plus and the minus right so it's really
it's going to look weird but we're going
to do it
um the minus part looks exactly like
this
but upside down right so it's gonna well
I guess it's gonna look like that it'll
approach I'll have another asymptote
down here and then what about this one
well it's going to be mirrored across
this way right so I guess it looks
something like that
is that all right
so there's the plus part of it
and here's the minus part of it and
that's all there is to it
okay oh
this by the way is why I saw you had
some before this is why if I gave you
this this is the reason why it's a
parabola but the other way right because
it's really saying hey it's just plus or
minus the square root of x what does the
square root of x look like there's a
square root of x and here's negative the
square root of x there's your sideways
Parabola right one part is made of the
minus the other part is better than plus
that's it okay
how you feeling Doris is that okay yeah
that would yeah okay so let's just
before you go let's just review right
because we just did a lot right
what I would suggest is whenever you get
one of these questions where they give
you an original function and you need to
do some kind of
um
function to the function like taking a
square root right the first piece of the
puzzle has to be you've got to get the
original function and graph that really
well if I didn't have a good graph of it
I'm stuffed like you saw how constantly
I was just going back to the diagram and
saying oh look it's above it's a below
that's your main instrument that's the
first thing the second thing is you're
going to look for the normal features
that you'll look for
um it's a bit sneaky though for the
square root I just know because I've
done them thousands of these questions
that this is an important value for
square roots right and so that's why
when I draw I'm looking for those
just by chance
suppose I didn't get this right remember
when we were looking for this intercept
and we're like oh it's one how
convenient might not be one of course
right maybe The Intercept was something
like three well somewhere else the graph
will probably intersect with one and so
you need to find that so in just the
same way as right here
remember we found the y-intercept and we
said sorry the x-intercepts we said let
y equal zero if you don't know where y
equals one like that hasn't come out in
some other part of the process you've
got to find it you you need to know
where that point is because it's
important to the shape of your graph
um and then after that I look to see
what the square root does and where it
takes you okay
um in the HSE would be would you draw
the original
the short answer is yes
um you know often a question will give
you quite specific guidance and they
will say they will even say draw both f
of x and the square root of f of x on
the same graph because they're actually
looking for you to do the process I just
described like look at the feature and
say like oh look there's the point of
intersection right the question will
guide you in the very unusual situation
where they might say just just graph the
square root of it and I don't want to
see the rest of it I would draw the
original graph in pencil and then I'd do
all of this in pen you know how in the
HSC they scan or all that kind of thing
and then I would rub out the original
graph okay because then you can cleanly
see the real graph that they want
however I mean here's a these little bit
of insight that I can give you right
what the HSC is trying to do what the
markets are trying to do is understand
if you
understand
um which is weird right they they need
to actually see the process that you
went through it's why working is so
important in all kinds of questions not
just graphing so I would find it highly
unusual if they specifically ask you
draw draw one and not the other they
know that the main way to do the square
root is to do the original thing so if
they ask you to put them both on one
graph